-Performing a few hits off
of her upcoming new album,
"Trendsetter,"
give it up for Coi Leray.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[Rapping] ♪ Yeah, they wanna eat
off my plate ♪
♪ They wanna eat off me ♪
♪ When I had my vision you
couldn't see it ♪
♪ I'm off to better things ♪
♪ I'm only doing...that's gonna
make me elevate ♪
♪ Only want people around
that's gonna make me better ♪
♪ Mm, mm ♪
♪ It's a mm-mm ♪
♪ They ask how I get that ooh ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Go best friend ♪
♪ We killin' em ♪
♪ No new friends ♪
♪ Get rid of them ♪
♪♪
♪ It's just me and my twinnem ♪
♪ Uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp and
watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Yeah, uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp
and watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Yeah, want a bad bitch like
me? Keep on wishin', baby ♪
♪ Keep on wishin', baby ♪
♪ Bust it open,
first you gotta kiss it, baby ♪
♪ Yeah, want another...
I go fishin', baby ♪
-♪ I go fishin', baby ♪
-♪ I never let these broke ass
dudes fix me, baby ♪
♪ I hop on top and ride that...
he actin' lazy ♪
♪ Yeah, this... soakin' wet,
it's drippin' like a navy ♪
♪ I call him, "Big Daddy,"
he call me, "Lil' Baby," uh ♪
♪ They know I'm the...
I need some tissue ♪
♪ Ayy, hold up, hold up,
hold up ♪
♪ All these diamonds different
color, color, color ♪
♪ I done ran up all
these commas, commas, commas ♪
♪ Eat the cookie
like a Nutter Butter-butter ♪
♪ Lick this...
like just fa-la-la-la ♪
♪ Island ting,
she a Bahama mama-mama ♪
♪ Do whatever for a dollar,
dollar, dollar ♪
♪ Gucci snake up on my collar,
collar, collar ♪
♪ Never gave that boy
my number ♪
-♪ Uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
♪ Watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
-♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp
and watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ I said, "Uh, push it, push it,
click, click" ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp,
watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Yeah, uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp,
watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Yo ♪
♪ Ain't... with Barbie, brr ♪
♪ Tae did my pink, Bob Marley,
brr ♪
-♪ Betcha a million ♪
-♪ Hold up, hold up, hold up ♪
♪ All these diamonds different
color, color, color ♪
♪ I'm the leader...
follow, follow, follow ♪
♪ I created this...
Tyler, Tyler, Tyler ♪
♪ Grab his mic and sing it,
fa-la-la-la-la-la ♪
♪ Uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp and
watch it blick, blick ♪
♪ Yeah, uh, push it, push it,
click, click ♪
♪ Yeah, pop up on the opp and
watch it blick, blick ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]